my goodness today might be a historic
day because Google deep M's Chad GPT
competitor Gemini is here we were
wondering what kind of secret AI does
Google have up its sleeve and today you
will know all about it I am so excited
and I was also surprised by this
appearing as I was catching up on some
music albums to listen to and found a
new favorite song with the same name ha
what are the chances so what can the
Gemini AI do boy did they come out with
guns blazing thus Gemini has a lot to
offer according to the marketing
materials it is absolutely insane and
fortunately look yes ha we also have a
paper to have a look at together this is
a multimodel AI it can have a look at
your math homework with hand written
notes no need to type in anything just a
photo and look it already found a silly
little mistake in this physics
derivation it explains what went wrong
and how to do it right beautifully it
can even give you new practice problems
and analyze your answers to that a
personal teacher that is amazing but
note that Chad GPT can do this too and
we'll see in a moment if it can do
things that Chad GPT cannot and we are
not done yet not even close in fact we
are just warming up dear fellow Scholars
this is two minute papers with Dr
car now have a look at this paper this
is a metaanalysis on different genetic
variants of particular diseases this
means a research paper written by hand
by looking up tens of thousands of
papers finding the handful of papers out
there that have relevant information to
a given topic Aggregate and compare
their findings and finally draw a
conclusion that is a Herculean task and
now hold on to your papers fellow
Scholars because Gemini can do this
automatically it can evaluate papers
rapidly and see how relevant they are
now little AI read the paper and extract
the relevant data from it look no
hallucinations allowed because we are
seeing where it got all this data from
According to Deep Mind it read through
hundreds of thousands of papers in just
one lunch break I have to say they have
incredibly productive lunch breaks over
there at Deep Mind Bravo now it can also
update the studies and the fact that
this is a multimodal AI it means that it
can deal with code audio image
video you name it not just text
fantastic but wait a second if it can do
all of that is it possible that it can
even write a paper H interesting
question well little AI update the
graphs with the new
information wow so far we needed this
kind of Herculean effort to summarize
this genetic research data up to 2019
and now we have all this data up to 2023
and all this in just one lunch break
automatically and Alpha code 2 is also
here the first version was roughly as
good as half the humans in coding and
now better than 85% of the human
competitors and all this in just one
version change so what can it do well it
can break down a Written Task and come
up with efficient Solutions here it came
up with a solution using dynamic
programming this is a college level
computer science algorithm that breaks
down a big difficult problem into
smaller easier problems such a short
elegant solution and make no mistake
this is not just coding this is
reasoning understanding and synthesis
loving it and now you can have this
incredible digital mind as a companion
or even as a teacher in your Journeys
and by double-checking and repairing its
own answers it can now write you a web
app in less than a minute it is not
going to be perfect but it is an
incredible first crack at a problem once
again Chad GPT can likely do this too
for you at least as well now I promised
that we will see if it can do things
that Chad GPT cannot
so can it well it is advertised as a
universal AI let's talk about that and
compare to CAD GPT because there are
absolutely insane insights there they
showcase incredible performance on the
MML U data set when I heard this my eyes
basically popped out of my head so what
does this mean this is the massive
multitask language understanding data
set it contains questions about Anatomy
astronomy chemistry formal logic
marketing management sociology virology
you name it so how good is it well this
is a good Human
Performance and this is Gemini yep that
sort of means superhuman performance now
this graph is from the marketing
materials but we are fellow Scholars
here we like research papers better so
there you go ah much better now let's
look at the comparison yes it claims to
beat Chad GPT but this comparison has
its limits Chad GPT was benchmarked with
five shot which means that the AI was
given five somewhat similar examples to
learn from where Gemini's Co stands for
Chain of Thought and these are important
details this means guiding the a model
through a stepbystep reasoning process
this is not entirely the same process as
the five shot but it gets better beyond
that in 30 out of 32 benchmarks it came
in first and many of these comparisons
are apples to apples comparisons you can
see the equivalent number of shots in
the comparisons on many data sets with
this I think it is fair to conclude that
on these data sets yes yes it can do
things that chat GPT cannot I told you
Google is coming with guns blazing and
wait if we can have this kind of
universality in an AI do you remember
the example with the genome data yes
this means that it can do this in any
area of science any topic same with the
math lessons any lesson Works my
goodness and Gemini comes in three sizes
Ultra
this is for the hardest of the hardest
tasks Pro this is the bread and butter
for most tasks and Nano this is a tiny
version for you to be able to run it in
your pocket yes right on your phone the
pixel 8 Pro is the first smartphone to
be able to run this now good news I'll
tell you in a moment how you can try it
but first two insane things from the
paper one the training took place across
multiple data centers depending on the
methodology that would possibly require
a computer network that is so fast that
it basically makes my head fall off that
is incredible two look at this this is
something that I could not believe for
years but it is here and it is true
specialist AI exist these are techniques
that are incredibly good at one thing
but cannot really do anything else like
alphao at go or Alpha fold at protein
folding and then there are generalist
AIS like gp4 and Gemini these can do a
lot of things but not as well as the
specialist AI that can do just one thing
until now and this is a historic moment
this is a universal AI that can beat
these specialist AIS at their own game
perhaps because knowing a little less
about your area but more about the world
in general makes you a better specialist
that is incredible a huge philosophical
thought that keeps me up at night so
much to think about so when can we try
it well according to google right about
now according to them the pro version is
available right now in Bard however not
for me as of the making of this video so
so I am assuming there is a staggered
roll out of this system likely it will
gradually be deployed to all of us very
soon I will note that we do not have any
business ties with Google or deep mind
or open AI none of our videos were
sponsored by them including this one of
course according to what we hear from
internal documents getting this Ai and
barred right might be an existential
issue for Google so they are putting all
their might into it and and I have to
say it shows wow very excited to give
this a try soon and if you see this
video make sure to try Google bard it
might already be infused by Gemini by
the time you are watching this the link
is in the video description what a time
to be alive and if you enjoyed this and
if you wish to see more become a fellow
scholar by subscribing and hitting the
Bell icon checking out our sponsor is
also a great way to support us thank you
so much experiment tracking model
evaluation and production monitoring for
your deep learning projects and llm apps
this is what weights and biases does and
it is the best everyone is using it try
it out now at wnb domme slapers or click
the link in the description below